Why won't the Germans do this?
I don't understand.
Like,
any time
you talk to an administration official,
they try to downplay the tensions
going on in naito,
but it's really spilling over.
It's really quite obvious.
You have the Polish Prime
Minister criticizing
Chancellor Schultz.
Why won't they
even just allow other countries
to give the leopard to?
No one knows for sure.
Jake, in my mind, it's
a lack of leadership.
The German seem
very reluctant
still to depart
from a decades old policy of ice politic,
where they try to make nice
with the Russians.
And it's the Ukrainians
are paying the price for it.
And one of the arguments
that that the Germans are making is
they don't want to go into this alone.
They want the Americans
to send some Abrams tanks,
which the Ukrainians
are not really asking for,
because the fuel is different there.
They're bigger. They're older.
What's the downside of the U.S.
sending a few of these tanks
just to satisfy the Germans?
Could that actually
I mean, the Russians
don't think of Germany as a threat,
but they certainly think of the U.S.
as one.
Does that play into it?
Well, first of all,
I think
the Biden administration is right
that the weapons are better
tank than the Abrams.
For all the logistical
and other reasons and
and I've been critical,
of course, of the Biden
administration in the past.
But on this one,
I think if the key is to send
a dozen Abrams
to unlock the Germans,
get it done,
send over a dozen Abrams tanks,
and allow
then Germany and Poland and Finland
and others
who have leopards as well, two
to provide it to the Ukrainians.
Because, look,
time is not on our side here.
We talk about a spring offensive
either by the Russians happening
sometime in March, about five weeks away
or preferably
the Ukrainians
launching their own offensive beforehand.
And it's going to take time
to deliver the tanks,
the train,
the Ukrainians up
to set up the supply lines
for logistics and maintenance.
Let's get it moving.
And I'm hopeful
I suspect this will get unlocked
in the next couple of days or so.
Do you think
how do you think it's going to go along?
I think they're all moving toward
a solution whereby
the Poles and Germans at the
highest level will get it done.
We had the German foreign minister today
say, well, if the Poland's want to send
if the Poles want to send it, go ahead.
We won't mind. Oh, okay. Right.
And so now
now the Poles are saying, well,
we want to hear from the chancellor.
So it looks like
they're inching their way toward this.
But look, again, if it takes a dozen
Abrams tanks to position
somewhere in western
Ukraine to unlock this,
let's get on with
the time is not on Ukrainian side.
If you were secretary of defense
right now,
what would you be arguing
that the US should be doing that the U.S.
is not currently doing?
Well, I'd send some tanks, right?
Like the Germans.
I still think they need attack
those long range precision missiles.
Why not to strike deep into Russia,
but to strike deep in Crimea
to knock out those shaheed drone
launch points
and to knock out other logistics
lines of communication
and all those things they need.
And third, the Germans
I'm sorry, the Ukrainians
need more air defense
to protect the cities
and then to protect themselves
going forward
as they move in offensive
Would you only give the attack arms
with the under
the provision
that they cannot
be used to fire into Russia,
they can only be used to fire
at Russian forces in Crimea?
Would that be like that?
That would be the rule.
If that's what it takes to get them
to get attack arms to to Ukraine?
Yes, there is a concern
that if you start striking deep
into Russia,
that you may turn the populate
the Russian population
alongside
Vladimir Putin
and you don't
want to unnecessarily escalate.
So in my mind,
A, provide them attack
arms, allow them to reach deep
into eastern Ukraine
and deep into southern Ukraine,
to include Crimea
again, to knock out those launch points
and logistic centers.
Take a listen
to the new chairman of the House
Foreign Affairs
Committee, Michael McCaul,
Republican of Texas,
talking to my college
colleague, Dana Bash
about the importance
of educating members of Congress
as there are a lot of,
as you know,
Republicans in the kind of MAGA
isolationist warning to those
who don't want to be involved in this.
The importance of educating them
as to why aid to Ukraine is so important.
Take a listen.
If Ukraine falls, Chairman Xi in
China is going to invade Taiwan.
If Russia, China, Iran is putting drones
in Crimea
and North Korea, that's putting artillery
into Russia.
Do you agree?
I do.
I've said from day one
that Beijing is watching very,
very closely
about how the United States
and its allies will respond.
And thankfully,
we responded
in a unified way comprehensively.
Financial sanctions, economic sanctions,
diplomatic sanction,
sanctions, and, of course,
military support
to push back on the Russians.
So everybody is watching.
I think this is a
smart investment
for the United States to continue
to provide arms,
ammunition and assistance to Ukrainians,
because Ukraine in defeat would be
would go a long way
toward knocking back one of our clear
near peer
or previously near peer competitors.
One of the knocks on the U.S.
government's support for this war
has to do with how
how good for profits
this is for
the military industrial complex.
You used to work for Raytheon,
which is a leading defense contractor,
which won
a massive $1.2 billion contract
with the Pentagon.
You don't work for them anymore. I know.
But how do you counter
that argument that, you know,
I'm not saying that I believe this,
but you only want this
because the military industrial complex
is getting fat.
I want this because
we are now in a
in a struggle
between autocracy and democracy.
This will be
the struggle of the 21st century
and it's important
that the Western democracies
band together and beat back
the Russian autocrat called
Vladimir Putin,
because like we said earlier,
a Jinping sitting in Beijing watching
and he's watching how we react
and how we will respond.
And every day that we continue
to remain unified and support
the Ukrainians is a day
that he backs off from any tensions
he might have against Taiwan.
Do you talk to any of the House
Republican leadership?
They're in charge now,
and I think there are
a lot of Republicans
who think the way you do
about international affairs,
who are worried about the Marjorie
Taylor Greene's and the other,
I don't want to
add whatever they are, isolationists,
whatever people
that were reluctant
to get involved in Ukraine
worry about their voices
getting louder and more powerful.
I've talked to senior members
on both sides of the aisle
and on the Republican side,
I think most most Republicans understand
this is important to do to do this
to support the Ukrainians,
that it's in our long term
national security interests to do so.
So I'm confident at the end of the day,
that will prevail.
I want to ask you,
there's a new book
from your friend and colleague,
Mike Pompeo called Never Give an Inch.
And there's an excerpt of mentions you.
Not that many, but this is one of the few
he writes on July 19th.
20, 20.
As I was on a flight back to D.C.,
White House Chief of Staff
Mark Meadows called me.
Mike Esper is not going to make it,
he said.
He added that the president told him
that he wanted me to do all hat
and take
on leading the Department of Defense
as an additional duty.
I told Meadows that
I thought that was a nutty idea.
Now, you survived
until a few months later.
What did you did?
Had you
heard about that before that he wanted
Pompeo to run the State Department
and the Pentagon?
Yeah, no,
I had not heard about that,
but of course, I knew,
you know,
when I pushed
back on the President's desire to use
active duty forces in the
protests in D.C.
in early June, and then I came out
and publicly spoke out against it.
I knew I was on thin ice
from that point forward.
So as I write in my memoir,
there were a number of things
I had to do to advance the ball
to protect the nation.
The national security,
what we we're trying to do,
and I continue to do
those as I push back on
what I thought were not smart ideas.
And my game plan was get to the election.
And fortunately,
I was able to do so under wasn't
I guess, a need to do.
Mike Pompeo, you got to the election.
Thanks so much for being here.
Appreciate it.
Mark Esper, former secretary of defense.
He.